[Musique]
ils ont été tués par une attaque de
drone à bislav dans le nord de la région
de rerson une zone où très peu de
journalistes sont présents car elle est
régulièrement bombardé par le kemelin ce
jeudi deux Français ont perdu la vie
dans l'est de
l'Ukraine la journée d'hier a été
marquée par le fait qu'une équipe de
volontaires dont des étrangers a essuyé
des tir dans le district de bislav deux
ont été tués c'est un exemple
terisme
r Paris est catégorique les deux
Français tués jeudi étaient bien des
humanitaires et travaillé pour
l'entraite protestante Suisse une ONG
éevette qui a elle aussi confirmé la
mort de ces deux
volontaires sur ses réseaux sociaux
Emmanuel Macron pointe lui aussi la
responsabilité sans équivoque du
cremelin deux humanitaires français ont
été tués en Ukraine par une frappe russe
acte lâche et indigne je pense à leurs
proches et camarad
blessés volodimir zensk a lui aussi
salué la mémoire des deux humanitaires
français et courageux selon lui le
gouverneur de la région deerson a lui
indiqué que trois autres humanitaires
étrangers ont été légèrement blessés
lors de cette attaque de drone
russe